opening credits of scientific wonderment
after the last movie Bruce Scott at
Norton plastic surgery but still feels
the need to hide in a South American
jungle Oh Jennifer Kylie looks like Liv
Tyler now Sam Elliott unconvincingly
changes into William Hurt the plastic
surgery epidemic in Hollywood has
officially gone off the rails movie
presses Delete on the last hole by
rehashing new origin story in the
opening credits we made a mistake hiring
an rtii director like Angley last time
now let's get the guy who did
transporter 1 & 2 usually we tell you
that a newspaper article doesn't match
the headline but here I'd like to point
out that some local resident claims he
saw a green sasquatch and investigators
seem to think he's telling the truth is
at Newton living in the same house he
didn't fight club okay science guy Bruce
Banner decides not to check anywhere
else figuring and I was probably all of
it real smooth Bruce also he stopped the
production line but still somehow missed
this obvious bottle with blood on it is
this movie actually gonna kickstart its
plot by saying someone drinks the
tiniest bit of Bruce's blood and gets
gamma poisoning oh yeah
the power of boners will make you decide
a hot girl is worth potentially blowing
your Hulk secret for not only they
should come follow me
you know what that's pretty funny and it
might make sense if we were in America
and a foreigner got hungry and angry
confused but in Portuguese hungry and
angry are like we different words man
chemistry things boredom I just sent my
blood to some stranger I don't know face
also how did this relationship ever form
is there some kind of dark web on the
internet for renegade gamma scientists
do you post a craigslist ad asking for
help with your gamma radiation project
and just hope the one other dude alive
that can help you seize it Stan Lee oh
wait that pulls me out of the movie also
if this is Stan Lee in the rebooted Hulk
movie which he races the last Hulk movie
then who was that Stan Lee in the
previous Hulk movie honking both Stan
Lee's coexist this Ford is named after
my penis but without my permission
and I don't need to read any potential
responses back from you so golf guy
who's trying to help me
also Bruce hits five keys on the
keyboard and nothing is on screen and
then he hits five more keys for a total
of ten key presses to type home these
military guys must have taught the fast
and furious guys when it comes to
covering all the exits in a Brazilian
slump well you know what maybe don't do
sexy undress e stuff in front of an open
window huh also she just happens to be
the same hot girl Bruce me we hoped out
over earlier unnecessary orders it was
inevitable this would end up on rooftops
wasn't it I mean damn how many times do
we need to see this I'm trying to escape
product placement oh come on it's like
Bruce's escape route is tailored to make
him run into every minor character from
the factory how is this heart beating
187 times a minute and he still hasn't
turned into the hole yet his body is
made up of such supposedly volatile
stuff that Stanley couldn't even enjoy
his Brazilian soda without getting gamma
radiation from a tiny drop of blood
Jesus this escape takes him to the
factory movie is nostalgic about its
first 15 minutes give me that I honestly
don't care if the special effects are
bad please stop cutting away from Hulk
every chance you get this happened in
the last hole and all we saw was
confused reaction shots and it's
annoying as hell what Jon's got lucky
it's not like every movie needs to
follow the jaws model when it comes to
showing the monster asshole soldier went
to the Prometheus school of running away
from things and never once takes any of
his side street options the supertrain
Russian badass is an awful shop bully
misspells the number zero it's asshole
went on a rage journey 3,000 plus miles
from Brazil to Guatemala Jesus
movie acknowledges the old TV show
Incredible Hulk theme song but in the
show it was David Banner and not Bruce
and the last movie had David and Bruce
so with those things in the second
Stanley my whole world is being blown up
right now reboot says you know the
flashbacks in the first movie weren't so
bad so let's keep doing those this is
actually the script of this movie back
here on the screen wall banners work was
very early phase II thought he was
working on radiation resistance excuse
me why do you have a scientist work on
the Captain America serum and tell him
he's working on radiation resistance how
do you hope to get what you want if the
scientist is testing for something else
plus why do you get good scientists to
do this when you can easily pay for evil
guys is this even relevant anymore Bruce
risks a lot just to catch a glimpse of
his lady he's literally got to be like
50 yards from some kind of military
secret service right Jesus the power of
boners use your head shrink that's
racist hey there's Lou Ferrigno playing
a security guard again this guy used to
be the Hulk but into Hulk movies with
different origin stories he's paul blart
and that's two people he's bribed with
pizza movie suggests pizzas a better
bribe than money
move your reinforces a stereotype that
you can easily guess computer passwords
of people he used to fuck a long time
ago not an anti-virus becomes in this
movie the very kind of adware their core
product promises to stop antivirus also
Ed Norton is using Norton AntiVirus the
entire irony is strong with this one
Betty Ross and her new boyfriend just
happened to show up after hours to the
pizza place where Bruce's would you
settle for a mr. orange mr. pink isn't
in this movie this was basically ty
Pharrell's role before Modern Family
he'd always be the nice guy who took the
main characters girl and had no chance
to keep her because everything he didn't
said screamed rebound Hey look it
started raining just at the time the
movie started getting emotional somehow
in this big-ass city she found the one
man walking in the pouring rain who was
also Bruce Banner who also isn't she
surely being followed by paranoid
patriot act dad's henchmen too much
pressure dad got in there before they
carted it all the way how you were in
the hospital after the incident did they
wait until your recovery to start taking
stuff out of the lab I don't understand
why we can't just go in there together
and talk to him you don't
military guys continue to be awful at
their job give everything away before
the operation starts you know how many
times does this guy have to get shot
before you just say and stop wasting the
ammo yeah it should work to be fair it
was useless with bullets to help chases
after Blonsky instead of just running
away which he obviously can do in a
blink after running that 3,000 mile
craziness at the beginning of the movie
where's the gunship does it matter
no some serious just went down time to
start raining you did the right thing
calling how did this guy know that Bruce
was with Betty sure he may have
suspected earlier that she was looking
for Bruce even though that's pretty
far-fetched dude but how does that
translate into I know for a fact she
found him later when driving through the
rain he spent the night and they're
definitely going to the University the
next day if you know all that they could
have snatched up Bruce while he was
sleeping at Betty's house no need to
take you to the hospital
we'll see what nature can do for your
smoke inhalation and unconsciousness
also whoever owns rain machines made a
killing on this movie and I never
realized before making these sins videos
how much the Hulk resembles King Kong in
terms of story beats well they didn't
really get the CGI any better this time
out today shiny hulk with shiny no
matter where no decides to relieve
stress he always finds the place with
the peaceful waterfall hope throws a
boulder got hold freaks out over a
thunderstorm cuz that's never happened
before when he's been Hulk apparently
this is basically the same hole we dealt
with in the first movie only less shots
of trees and fungus it's almost like the
universal blamed all the Angley SH for
the failure of the last movie and none
of the other stuff we didn't like is
this supposed to be a surprise I mean
nobody said this guy was dead and we
kind of figured the serum would give him
extra powers so what's with the horror
movie villain cliche Bruce I'll get a
room you just stay here by the Coke
machines okay get my data back you hate
it this guy swallowed a flash drive and
his stomach acids didn't destroy the
thing or make it inoperable Wow
sophomores Jack McGee and Jim Wilson
witnessed some of the battle Jack McGee
is a sophomore in college in the story
what is this Incredible Hulk babies the
footage the news happens to show is
nothing sure he captured exactly what
the news shows but are they saying he
turned his camera off and didn't get
actual footage of the Hulk
hey come on are we saying now that sex
causes the guy to honk Alan you're
making me horny you wouldn't like me
when I'm horny also it took all sorts of
nonsense to get Bruce at 200 beats per
minute earlier in the movie now we're
going to include sexist things that get
your heart rate to halt changing levels
I can't get too excited tell me in all
those months in Peru you didn't
masturbate once have a nocturnal
emission like God man that might be the
problem sir
it's philosophy I won't tell you what
it's about just get over to the
emergency room and be stunned by the
dramatic reveal
um heaps sitting down how are we gonna
get where we need to go on $40 and no
credit cards that's the exact same
question that launched cinemasins
actually the alias is mr. green and mr.
blue have been added to the shield
operations database Bruce decides to
title this message something very easy
for any spying Security Agency to find
okay so he swallowed this bomb flash
drive and stomach acid did nothing and
the thing still works fine but this is
2008 and he's in bump smoky mountains
countryside at a rundown gas station and
he found a computer with working
internet access and a USB port on the
keyboard
why are you documenting your fugitive
run from the lawn like it's a damn
honeymoon I'm assuming this is a secret
place anyway so why the privacy Kirk for
drama maybe me and a metal tube deep
underground with hundreds of people in
the most aggressive city in the world
let's get a cab you like you're going to
encounter 1975 New York down in the
subway but damn are we saying you have
no control over this beast anymore
you took all those breathing classes and
everything also of course movie unearths
the long-forgotten crazy cab driver
drives crazy and his crazy cliche
welcome back old friend we haven't
missed you why hasn't the military sworn
this office already they know who mr.
blue is and they know Bruce is coming to
meet him so what's the freaking holdup
Oh hitting the Machine makes it work
cliche things I should have told you
before strapping into this table but
let's just do this by the seat of our
pants shall we it's hard to know because
none of our test subjects ever survived
how was this a surprise you mean dr.
Stearns has been experimenting with
Bruce's blood without ever mentioning
any of the experiments he conducted and
it's not like he's being secretive he's
like come on back to my lamp below your
blood where we've been studying gamma
magic Bruce this is all you you didn't
send me much to work with so I had to
concentrate it and make more weight is
that possible you can make gallons of my
blood from one tiny sample because the
Red Cross still doing blood drives for
then punched a black cliche the mixture
could be an abomination you know like
what we'll call you is your proper name
once you become that general Ross flew
off once the mission was done but leaves
his bio soldier to run around unchecked
so Stern's can inject him with even more
gamma goofiness let's eat seems like you
wouldn't allow a prisoner especially
like Bruce to do this but okay tender
moment is tender movie suddenly turns
into a more expensive Cloverfield also
god alone that villain has the same
powers as that he wrote both Marvel did
the same year with Iron Man yep he fell
in a way that Bruce's blood drops are
going to land precisely on his tiny open
wound this movie is a dick you should
come take a look at this cliche yeah
yeah I know he said here but same thing
get ahold of yourself man come on like a
soldier is going to make that up also
stop acting like it's impossible if you
just raided a lab owned by a guy who was
studying hawk blood and you have an
imbalance soldier out there Apollo
Theater and movie both experienced
Amateur Night at the same time yep that
actually is Omar Michael K Williams from
The Wire playing I kid you not
Harlem bystander years after the wire
had premiered
so was this blonsky's lifelong dream
when he got this kind of power go on a
rampage in New York he can do almost
anything he wants and it's do what the
Cloverfield monster and Godzilla has
done I don't know that's the first time
any soldier has ever asked that in these
movies it's apparently not a Marvel
movie if someone isn't free falling to
earth from high in the sky above yeah
but his human body crashed through the
street how did he honk out after he
definitely died from that fault how does
he even remember why he's here why isn't
he fleeing or looking for hot chicks or
something Wow someone saw Matrix
Revolutions damn it general Ross is one
of the most brain-dead characters I've
ever witnessed everyone survives this
well this isn't exactly rotating around
the earth to turn back time but it might
as well be hulk stops the region fire
with his mighty wind clap it probably
should have also knocked the helicopter
off the roof it was so forceful but lady
doesn't think abomination should be
killed for some reason who are all these
people
especially this mom and her kid going to
the place where two giant green things
are causing mass destruction everywhere
they go yeah better get a closer look at
that wait did he want to turn into the
Hulk right now but why he's in British
Columbia and the only thing he can rage
against there is Wolverine also since
this movie's Canon within Marvel's The
Avengers how does this asshole end up in
Calcutta ah the Incredible Hulk
the one movie in the Marvel Universe to
actually put that post-credit scene at
the end of the actual movie instead I
could kiss this movie for doing what
every other movie should have done its
problem with this is it makes the movie
official Marvel Canon which is bad for a
whole bunch of reasons you're putting it
together yeah Tony that's a classic
pronoun game nobody in the whole
audience knows this we you're talking
about or is 1.5 billion worldwide
interested in seeing such a thing get
more dead to me and your dead mother
this is Brazil
I can't bring myself to regret the
decision to leave home I would miss
Phoenix
I'd miss the heat what's your favorite
dish I'm not gonna cook it but I'll
order it from Zanzibar I don't know why
you cry but it's something I can never
do now I'm gonna count to three if you
don't open that case I'm gonna I'm
loading your face
in the ear here's the question the
comics probably answer but I'm too lazy
to research if Bruce doesn't shave does
he sometimes have a Hulk beard and if so
wouldn't all the individual hair is
growing width in size but also in
distance apart from one another making
it an odd puffer fish of a beard or what
a bunch of new pores and hairs appear to
help cover the now much larger Hulk face
regardless I know the folks at Harry's
have shaving products that could handle
the whole kiyose two beards
I've tried it myself and you can too at
Harry's Calm using the special code for
our fans cinemasins you'll get five
dollars off your first purchase it's
actually I'm not even mad that's amazing
it convenience and affordability of
Harry's is obvious but it's an added
bonus that the reason reserved such fine
quality this is Valyrian steel so
whether you make facial hair choices for
reasons of style masculinity or plain
old laziness like me Harry's has all
kinds of great razors and other shaved
products they will be happy to ship to
your door for a crazy good price learn
more or sign up today and get five
dollars off your first order at Harry's
Calm using the code cinemasins